I know you got your wants and needs
streaks we all know that and I'm not
sure if you're trying to make headlines
or actually trying to find your love but
and that's a big old but we know Kim
this is going to drain you from your
energy homie straight up and then you're
gonna be like Kanye all up in the news
these days all up on your worst behavior
you don't need that in your life because
I know how it goes bro you're hollering
at a girl you see her out then it just
starts with one dance and then you're
like all right just hold on we're going
home we know that one and then you're
saying songs like she's the best you
ever had and now she my friend is in
controlla you don't need that in your
life next thing you know you're all sad
you wake up it's 5 a.m in Toronto and
you all up in your feelings Drake not a
good look and you're thinking I'm gonna
Jump Man Jump Man Jump Man don't do it
okay remember you the sixth God you
started from the bottom Drake you had
nothing going on you went from zero to a
hundred real quick so you need to know
yourself Drake now go out there and make
me proud Drake take care of yourself
because it's all God's plan